For more complex validation,
you've got the constraint
validation API which allow you
to harness the power of JavaScript
to validate inputs on the fly.
Here let me show you how it works.
The core of the constraint validation
API is this function, setCustomValidity.
And as you could see,
it's getting a string.
setCustomValidity makes
the assumption that if you
pass a none empty string to it,
the input is invalid.
So it displays an error message.
That means that the opposite is true.
If you pass an empty string to it,
then the input is valid.
In practice, simply set a callback on an
inputs, on input event like we did here.
And at the end of the callback,
call setCustomValidity on the input.
If we type in something like that,
we will get the error message.
And if we are typing correctly,
we're passing the test.
Good job.